hello in this video i explain to you
what a simple and multiple line
recession is how you
can calculate it online and how you
interpret the results and with that
we start a
regression analysis which allows you to move
from one or more variables
to another variable  close
or predict them
let's say you want to find out what has
an influence on a
person's salary you could use, for
example, the highest educational
qualification the weekly working hours
or the age of a person you could
now examine whether these three variables have
an influence on a person's salary
person have if so if this is the
case then you can preview a
person's salary by showing
the person's highest level of education the person's
weekly hours worked and
the person's age the
variable duh wants to infer is
the one you want to say more likely  means
dependent  ge variable or criterion
the variables you use to predict
herms are called independent variables or
protectors recession analysis can have two
purposes.
you can measure the impact of one
or more variables on another
variable or predict a variable
based on other variables
the simple  linear version is
used when you have an independent
variable to infer dependent
variables in example where
we want to predict a person's salary
we apply only one variant
either whether or not one has a degree
the weekly hours worked or
a person's age in the multiple  you
closer region several
independent variables are used
to infer the salary you use
the highest educational qualification the
weekly working time and the age
of a person and all three variables
at the same time in one model hence the
difference between a simple  and
a multiple recession is that in
one case only one independent variable
is used and in the other case
several both have in common that the
dependent variable is metric a
metric variable are, for example,
a person's salary,
height, shoe size or, for example, the electricity
consumed by
the  opposite is the logistic
region the logistic recession is
used when you have a categorical
dependent variable but this video
is about the linear regression
the logistic person is looked at in a
separate video in this
playlist so we have the simple
linear regression has the weekly work
hours  an impact on the
hourly wage of employees we have
only one independent variable and we
have the multiple linear regression
do the weekly hours worked and
the age of employees have an
impact on their hourly wage
here we have two independent variables
weekly ar  working time and age
and both going at the same time
during recession model series let's start
with simple linear regression the
goal of simple line regression is
to predict the value of a dependent
variable from an independent variable
how greater the
linear relationship between the unep
variable and the dependent variable  is
the more accurate the prediction is visually
, the relationship between the
variables can be represented in a scatter
diagram, the
greater the linear
relationship between the dependent and independent
variants is, the more the
data points are on a straight line, the task
of simple linear regression is
now exactly that  precisely to determine which
best describes the linear connection between the dependent and the independent variable within the framework of the
linear
regression analysis, a straight line is drawn in the
scatter diagram in order to
determine this directly  t the linear
regression to the method the core
is squared back let's say
I had commissioned a hospital and you
should give an estimate in the hospital based
on the age of a
person how long this person will stay
in the hospital after an operation the hospital operator would like
his planning here
optimize your dependent variable so that you
want to shower is
the length of stay after an op
the independent variable is the age
the equation that describes your model
now looks like this y roof is
the estimated length of stay iks is
the age is the slope of the straight line
and is  er on point that doesn't make
much sense but if a person is 0 years
old they would stay in the hospital more precisely days
because we're
starting at zero
accordingly the estimated
length of stay is exactly that's our on
point otherwise this slope is described
by the coefficient b
so that you can calculate the coefficients b
the hospital must of course give you
a random sample of people
whose age and
length of stay after an operation you can calculate with the data available here you could now get doubts out that b is 0.14
and 1.2 that is now your model with
where you can estimate the length of stay after an operation based
on the age
let's say a person who is 33
years old is registered for an operation
then we put x3 and 30 years 1
our model now tells us that this
person after an operation 5,8  stays in the
hospital for two days now
the question is of course how do you calculate the strong
b and the points
you usually use a
statistics program like data tab for
this, but in the case of simple linear regression it
is also quite easy to do it by hand
the coefficient b
the
standard deviation of the
length of stay after an operation results from the correlation between age and length of stay after an operation  dividing
by the standard deviation of the
age results from taking the
mean
value of the length of stay after the operation and subtracting b from the
mean value from the age
the recessions are currently trying to map
the given data with
a straight line as best as possible of course there
is always an error
this error is called apps i lon
say we estimate the
length of stay of a person who is 33
years old our model says that
this person stays 5.8 two days in the
hospital so we look at
the x-axis at the age 33 and
look  where we are meeting her right now the
age would be 5.82
this person actually stays
in the hospital for seven days
then the difference between the
estimated value and the value of the goods is our
error exactly the error is
called epson so you now have one  good
overview of what simple linear
regression is and we come to
multiple linear  e regression
as opposed to simple line region
, multiple linear
regression allows two or more independent
variables to be considered the objective is
to estimate one variable on the basis of several
other variables
the variable to be business is
referred to as the dependent variable
criterion the variables
which  are used for the prediction
are called independent variants
relate laws projectors with
multiple linear regression the
influence can therefore be controlled by a third variable
the multiple line
recession is often used in
empirical social research as well as in
market research
in both areas it is
of interest to find out which
influence  have different factors on one
variable so as we already
know the equation for
simple linear regression looks like this we
have one independent variable let's go down
the route to multiple linear
regression wi  r several independent
variables so we have the first
independent variable we have the
second independent variable and we
have the map independent variables the
coefficients can now be interpreted in a similar way to
the lines regional
line are all independent variables
0 comes out the value changes an
independent variable  by one unit,
the associated call indicates, for example, how much
the dependent variable changes, so
let's say that's the age and that's
the salary of a person if
the age changes by one year, then
the salary of the person changes by b 1,
say  want to estimate a
person's salary by querying their
gender the person's age
and the person's weight the
coefficient for the variable gender
would then be - 372 the coefficient becomes the
age would then be 25.39 for the weight 51
56 and we had  the point of 1920
so if everything is 0 we get a
salary of 1920 a person di  a person who is one year
older earns 25.39 euros more and
a person who is a kilogram
heavier earns 5 eur 51 less if the
person is male they would
earn 372 euros less than
a woman in
this example these are of course just example data
and now i will show you  taught you how
you can calculate a regression analysis online
and have the results interpreted
for this please go to date up de
click on the statistics calculator
and if you
want to use your own data the table and
just copy it into this table
I use the example acts  we
want to calculate a recession so
let's just click on regression
say we want to
predict a person's income for this
we take their gender age and
weight now datatec will
automatically calculate a linear regression for you and
you get the results down here
either you can  just
click on summaries words then
gets  you a summary of the
recession in words or you go
through the individual tables
you can also
check the requirements for the revision
but there is a separate video for this
you can see the model
summary the hannover and the
coefficients on these three tables
now let's go into more detail
so the results will be presented in this
form
you can of course
simply look at the interpretation in words
but we will now go
through each block individually and we will start
easily with the model summary
we will start with the multiple
correlation sco efficient  he
this captures the connection or the
correlation between the dependent
variable and the independent variable
so that it is clearer we see
the equation above again your
statistics program how datatec calculates
the recession
coefficients you
can calculate the regression efficient back here  If you multiply all the
variables by the recession 15
and add them up, then
you get a value back here
and of course you have the dependent
variable. If you now calculate the correlation between the
dependent variable and all
the values ​​added up
, then you have the multiple
coalition coefficient. Here
we come  to the next parameter the r
square r square is also called variance
explanation it indicates how much of
the variance of the dependent variable
can be explained by the independent variables
your dependent variable has a
certain variance the more we can explain of this
variance by the independent variables
all the more  our model is better
let's take the example of how
long you stay in the hospital after an operation of course not everyone stays in the hospital
for the
same amount of time
that's why we have a fluctuation
we want to explain exactly this fluctuation with the help
of regression analysis,
for example with the alt  he under
operation art predict the length of stay very
well the r square is very
large we can even clarify
everything that of course will not happen in reality
one would come out in
that case we can only predict exactly how long with the age
and the operation sad
person stays in the hospital after an operation
but as I said it
will of course not come out so in
summary the variance
explained how good your model is and
it is between 0 and 1 1 is very
good 0 is not
good we also have the
adapted r  square the r square
overestimates the variance elucidation
especially when there are a lot of
independent variables for this
one uses the adjusted one he
then corrected this and
finally we have the standard
estimation error derstandard.at
schweder indicates how much the model is  the
prediction of the dependent variable on
average misestimated in the example what
we calculate  t we want to
estimate the salary of a person our
estimation error now tells us that we are underestimating
ourselves by 672 euros if we want to
predict the salary of a person
again going back to the
example with the hospital it should come out here,
for example, that the
standard estimation error  ten days is
definitely what the hospital operator will say
hey unfortunately the model doesn't do me
much good because if I have a standard
estimation error of ten days then
I can't plan with it,
but should it turn out that the
standard is only two days again, the
hospital operator could say hey cool that
is a good prediction
we are trying to work with it, so depending on what you want to do
with the recession model
, you look more at the
standard error of estimation or that it
or the square of the regression is used for the
prediction.
the standard set of errors is actually more interesting
than you  mainly
interested in it  how badly the model
misjudges if you want to know the influence of
several variables on another
variable then you are interested in he
that he squared
then there is also the statistical
validation the f test is made
to check the zero hypothesis whether the
variance explained r squared  in
population 0 the test is often not
of much interest
the test is tantamount to
meaning that all were
slope percentages in population 0
are 10 to 20 and going all the way up
in this case because we have very little
data even comes up  from the fact that the
significance value is greater than 0.05
and the new hypothesis is
thus retained so and with that we now come
to the table that is probably the
most interesting one here we see
the and standardized
coefficients the standardized
coefficients and the significance level
gross b the  and standardized codes
ducks are precisely the coefficients that
but reze  ssion model
so if we
want to predict the salary
we have a constant of 1920 this
is our constant - the value for the
variable gender thirst the value of
the variable age and the variable
weight so we can
set up our recession models with the standardized efficient ones
if we want to predict salary we just have to insert
the variables
peter are the standardized
coefficients here you can see
which variable has the greatest influence
on salary in this case age has
the greatest influence on
salary age has the greatest value
and  finally we still the
significant values ​​smaller than 0.05
are considered as significant in
this case we see that not a single
coach is significant which means
that the new hypothesis is that
these coefficients in the
population are 0 if the
significance is greater than 0,  05 is
we can this 0 hypothesis nic  reject ht and
it is therefore still assumed
that these and standardized
coefficients are actually 0 in the population as a whole
because I used
a very small data set here
it is difficult
to come up with significant values, which
are still missing are the prerequisites
for your actions with them at all
you can calculate a regression you
will explain the requirement in the next
video, so see you soon,
ciao